elle me pousse dans les escaliers et là
je me retrouve encerclé parole trois
maps d'un mètre 80 j'ai un bel 95 42 kg
je comprends rien à ce qui se passe rien
que dalle ou à l'eau
[Musique]
j'ai fait le défilé etam la semaine
dernière en petite tenue parce que j'ai
toujours rêvé de montrer ce corps de
rêve au grand public
et là je me dis il faut que je frappe
plus fort le défilé etam s'est tellement
bien placé con qu'on le soupçonne
d'avoir truqué l'événement d'être en
collaboration avec étape non mais ça va
pas oui ça va pas alors j'ai un fils
très chanel le plus grand le plus beau
le plus prestigieux de tous les défilés
chanel
je vois donc le système mis en place des
invitations tout le monde qui arrive
avec son passeport il faut présenter sa
carte d'identité son invitation
son visa diplomatique et là je dis bah
on est foutu on recommence à inventer
moult mito pour pouvoir entrer dans ce
cet endroit réservé à la haute à la
haute société
ça marche pas ça marche pas rien ne
marche
et là on se retrouve nez à nez avec
quelqu'un d'un peu débordé et là on
s'est faufilé on est rentré dans la jv
d'abord tout lentement d'un escalier je
pousse un peu les gens autour de moi et
puis je fonce et puis je vois sur le
podium que les grandes tapes mada sont
en train de poser là haut en train de
taper la pause et que moi je me
retrouvais juste avec les petites top
model de merde de chasse
je les ai donc rejoint à un moment et je
me retrouve donc en face de cette femme
charmante que je ne connaissais point ni
d'eve ni d'adam
on va parler avec une agressivité sans
mots qui me traiter de 2
femme de base étages avec un tir haut
maria ce genre d'attitude très très
américaine a une attitude agressive
d'américaines enragé de 17 ans je me
suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'elle a
[Musique]
elle me pousse dans les escaliers là je
me retrouve encerclé parole trois maps
d'un mètre 90 au 1095 42 kg je sors mon
téléphone pour appeler mon chevalier je
sais pas ce qu elles ont crû de
téléphone j'étais presque mais là ça a
été la débandade
tu as 15 - comme ça pour me voler le
téléphone et là j'ai hurlé mais j'ai
parlé comme un cochon qu'on égorge
voilà j'ai montré un peu qui était la
française en moi 2 tu me parles comme ça
betsch non mais ça va pas et donc là
j'ai donc elles ont un petit moment de
recul était que je sais que là j'écarte
le marteau gcard jj je me fais un chemin
et là je me retrouve entouré par cette
vague d'agents de sécurité il y avait la
créatrice qui arrive qui dit mais qu'est
ce que c'est comme ça vraiment elle
était comme ça qu'est ce que c'est
l'autre qui vous êtes et agents de
sécurité qui
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel qui
vous êtes qui vous êtes ça commence à
sentir le roussi
bien bien le pire pour eux c'est le
scandale c'est le pire qui puisse
arriver
donc là je commence à gueuler mais
qu'elle est cassé vous qui vous dites je
suis personne je suis ta mère est là il
commence à vos lampes faire peur on
voudrait votre pièce d'identité etc
présence d'esprit de meuf qui se fait
souvent embarqués
il n'y a que la police en france qui a
le droit de demander la pièce d'identité
donc si ils veulent ma pièce d'identité
il appelle la police parlait de sai à ce
moment là je viens dit je veux partir je
veux sortir etc
il y avait deux équipes l'équipe qui
voulait me faire rester pour me créer
des noises et des ennuis l'équipe qui
veut me faire sortir je ma copine un peu
plus avec l'équipe de me faire sortir je
suis sorti comme ça tu sais entouré par
deux deux grands monsieurs très très
sexy mais les légendes ne touchait
presque pas le seul mais j'étais quand
même chic tu vois comme ça et puis en
deux minutes j'étais dehors attacks and
cigarettes
passons pourquoi j'ai fait ça est ce que
c'est le milieu qui se prend le plus au
sérieux au monde
on parle de vêtements on parle de choses
sympathiques on parle d'un milieu
artistique on s'éclate
tout le monde fait la gueule prend ses
terres déprimée parce que c'est plus
qu'au se prend au sérieux
il ya une absence d'humour gigantesque
c'est le milieu où il y a le moins
d'humour au monde en politique au moins
on peut déconner dans la mode personne
ne rigole jamais et donc j'ai fait ce
défi j'ai réalisé ce défi de montrer
qu'on peut rire avec la mode
j'ai même fait rire anna wintour